[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello walter hi martin
are you doing well
i'm not going to answer you okay so
we'll skip that part what do you have in
store for us today
well we're going to talk about the wars
roe versus wade hegelian dialectic
fireballs
all these things that some of our
theologians call conspiracies
so let's ask the lord for a blessing on
this discussion
our heavenly father once again we are
here to ask your blessing
and to guide us
through this discussion and to enlighten
our minds with the holy spirit and we
thank you for all of that in jesus name
amen amen
martin
if you attempt to place current events
into the prophetic picture
then you're bound to have some enemies
right yeah
but
that comes with the territory
and i don't think we should allow that
to deter us from our objective
so
let's jump right into the prophetic
picture and the times we are living in
and see if we can
find any interesting correlations
now we've had some
spiritual lectures of late or talks of
late
so now let's contemplate
the current events and fit them into the
picture and i think we'll have more than
one on this
portion because there's so much
happening it's hard to keep up right
to get all together you start
putting a powerpoint slide together and
before you know it it's grown so much
that you have to start all over again
and get this piece in and that piece in
and cut that piece out
anyway it's amazing how things are
developing in the world
let's start off again with this letter
and manuscript story about nashville
and i know we've spoken about this
before
but this is a prophecy
and sooner or later
if we believe that it is a prophecy
then it should come to fruition right
and we read here when i was in nashville
i had been speaking to the people and in
the night season there was an immense
ball of fire that came right from heaven
and settled in nashville
there were flames going out like arrows
from that ball houses were being
consumed houses were tottering and
falling
some of our people were standing there
it is just as we expected they said
we expected this others were wringing
their hands in agony and crying unto god
for mercy you knew it they said and you
knew that this was coming and never said
a word to warn us
they seemed as though they would almost
tear them to pieces to think that they
had never told them or given them any
warning at all
why start with something like this
martin
of course
it's this may be pertaining to nashville
but there's the same warning for the
whole world and all the cities
so basically it's a warning get out of
the cities get out of the cities there
are things happening
why would they
finger nashville here well nashville as
you know is the music center right we've
spoken about that before as well
and all kinds of music come out of there
it's supposed to be quite a conservative
area
but you know as we often find in these
very conservative areas that there is a
very liberal push as well in the same
district
so let's have a look why
tennessean said nashville's athena
statue was unveiled more than 30 years
ago and we haven't stopped oohing and
eyeing
for decades the full-scale replica of
the ancient parthenon stood in national
but without its athena
that changed may 2019
when the 42 foot tall athena partheno
statue was unveiled to a crowd of
thousands
the unveiling was a huge affair with
more than 5
700 people filling into the parthenon
to walk by and view the statue
and then for 12 years athena was a plain
white statue then in 2002
athena was gilded in gold to more
closely resemble the original according
to metro parks the project also included
painted details on her face wardrobe and
shield
so basically this is a replica of the
parthenon full scale by the way that's
it
it's quite a magnificent building
and they have this
in my opinion
quite ugly
athena standing in it
42 feet tall that's quite impressive yes
so
obviously
you can see this as a tribute
to the once
spectacular sight that was in athens
or maybe it's just a rebuild of
of pagan worship
pagan worship well either way it sends a
message to the world that they align
themselves
now not everybody in nashville of course
aligns themselves with this but it does
send out a particular message
and at the time
there was quite a furore in 1990 during
the unveiling ceremonies of athena
statue
in centennial park on may 20 1990 the
reverend mal perry stands at the
entrance of the park to protest athena's
role as a pagan image
and he had a
placard which says idolatry comes to
nashville in guise of ark
and he quotes exodus and acts and first
john so
martin would you say that there is this
conflict between the pagan element and
the christian element
definitely and if you take this that you
said guise of art yes wasn't art also
very prevalent
in the ancient times yes of course and
if you make that plural the arts
then it includes includes jesuit theater
and music and music and all of these
things so this is basically
symbolic of
of a certain message
and this is not really a subliminal
message it's a pretty blatant message
so nashville is a is an interesting
crucible
where
ideologies collide
now what if
disaster struck
nashville
which side would that strengthen
the conservative
ah
all right so it's just an interesting
thought
it would send this pendulum
to the right
and people would say yes we told you so
we told you so because because of this
art the pendulum was swung to the left
all right so let's just use this story
as a as a stage setter for our
discussion
at the moment the pendulum is hanging
towards liberalism
but there are a lot of noises that seem
to indicate that that pendulum might be
swinging back towards conservatism right
yeah because not long ago
with
just the previous administration it was
quite
to the right and and then it swung
supersonically
to the left
and now there is such a hoo-ha it might
just swing back to the right right
now how do you let that pendulum swing
what do you do
to make it swing well you play a game
and it's called the hegelian dialectic
where you
allow these
opposites to clash
[Music]
until you get what you want
that's it
and
in the in in the process you have the
pendulum swinging from one side to the
other and eventually it will swing so
far
to one side
that it might swing even further to the
other side
and then you might find a fulfillment of
process prophecy in the process is that
possible that's exactly how it is
supposed to eventually work out
according to the bible yeah it's
interesting in this
vision that ellen white had
she spoke about the pillars that came
down
now
this building the parthenon is of course
a building that consists of pillows
but there were other buildings
constructed afterwards around it making
almost like a complex also with pillars
so it's just interesting and we're not
being predictive about times or anything
it's about the ideology that's it about
two ideologies that are clashing and
that ideology is not only seen in
nashville and that's why
it will get to those parts later yes
well this is what it looked like when it
was still white here on the left
and now what it looks like in its gilded
form
and uh
i don't know would you bow down to it
martin definitely not i don't think
there's anything worth bowing down to do
you
but it's just the symbolic message
and here's an article in wikipedia and
you can see that it is a full-scale
replica of the parthenon
nashville's nickname is the athens of
the south influenced the choice of the
building as the centerpiece
of the
1897 centennial exposition so this comes
a long way
so this comes after the religious
awakening yeah so
there's a pendulum there exactly
religious awakening the pendulum was on
the right
and then you have this interposition
and the pendulum swings the other way
and it's right in the center
of this biblical belt yes
a number of buildings at the exposition
were based on the ancient originals
however the parthenon was the only one
that was an exact reproduction
it was also the only one that was
preserved by the city
although the knights of pythius pavilion
building
was purchased and moved to nearby
franklin tennessee
so we're talking about ideologies and
we're talking about
possible prophetic fulfillment there's
something else that's interesting in
nashville
and
this comes from crooks taking the
catholic pulse june 19 2022
and there you have the dominican sister
helps with work on new translation of
the book of revelation
now martin
will that be a protestant view
no definitely not
no definitely not and
who is being portrayed
as the bad guy in
the book of revelation the
correct original one well of course
that's the beast
it might be interesting and his
associates
so this is also something that is
happening in nashville so for the past
five years
sister mary dominique pitts of the
dominican sisters of saint cecilia
congregation in nashville
has been deep in study
of the book of revelation you know
martin perhaps we should send her a
couple of
dvds
all right the man behind the mask
and send her a couple of uh what's ups
that we've been doing and see what the
result of that would be yeah
definitely a good idea okay quoting the
project's website she said the purpose
of the translation is to create the most
extentful
and helpful set of notes for the entire
bible with information of interest both
to biblical scholars and casual readers
the best approach contributes to the
richness of scripture in for example
biblical polyphony
resulting from the different versions
and will restore the catholic feel
and appreciation of god's many voices in
scripture she added
so
we want this poly sound nashville is the
place of sound so let's send poly sound
into the world rather than mono sound
mutton
i like the mono sound of this book
don't you definitely do you want a poly
sound of it no
if i may make a pun
couldn't it then be phony
[Laughter]
might just then start to sound like a
clanging symbol correct
martin there's only
one word of god you can't have polyphony
biblical polyphony
different sounds
so that different versions will restore
the catholic field
only if there are different versions
can you actually restore the catholic
field
because that is called babylonian
confusion yes
so we we seem to be getting babylonian
confusion out of nashville we seem to
have paganism we seem to have a clash
with some of the conservatives at least
in the 1990s
so it's interesting to see what will
happen in this particular
place
so martin
let's just go to monophony
and have a look at what the bible has to
say about the end times
and we know these verses but just to set
the stage
revelation 13
14 and deceivers them that dwell on the
earth by means of those miracles this is
now the second beast of revelation
the one that comes out of the earth and
not out of the sea in other words not
out of the multitude of nations but the
separate power
that arose
in an area not populated by
by nations at that time
so it refers to the united states of
america
and it had power with these miracles to
do in the sight of the beast
so there's association between the
second power and the beast power which
is catholicism
saying to them that dwell on the earth
that they should make an image to the
beast which had the wound by the sword
and did live
so the image of the beast
will
develop
and it has to be an image of the beast
an image is something that looks like
the original we just saw a statue that
was an image and it was like the
original apparently
so what was the original the original
was a church and state union
the church made the rules
and the state executed them
that's what it was right
so in other words this is a prophecy
that in the united states of america the
church would once again make the rules
and the state would implement them
that's exactly what it says now whether
you do that openly or whether you do
that clandestinely is is irrelevant as
long as it happens
so this is a prediction that church and
state will come together which is of
course contrary to the constitution
and this image to the beast that had the
wound
by the sword and did live tells us that
the first beast is definitely not dead
but he has a lackey who does his work
for him yes that he doesn't get all the
flag
yes so he is
like
herodias
whispering into the ear of salome the
daughter
telling her ask for the head of john the
baptist
and sooner or later she's going to do
that but not to make it too obvious
they'll make it a blanket law
and lop of some heads besides those of
john the baptist right
very good and in verse 15 it says and he
had power to give life unto the image of
the beast
that's interesting he had power to give
life unto the image of the beast that
the image of the beast should both speak
and cause
and as many as would not worship the
image of the beast that they should be
killed
so there is a death decree coming martin
that is a biblical prophecy that's not a
conspiracy
so this second power
the united states of america
will become
like the first beast
it will be a church and state union and
somebody is whispering into its ear as
to what it should do and how it should
be done
but in order to achieve that you have to
sway public opinion yes
so that's where your pendulum comes
that's where the hegelian dialectic the
game comes in and you have to manipulate
the media
because you want
the media to impress ideologies into the
minds of men even conflicting ideologies
so that in the end you can have a
synthesis
and important to remember
it will be on both
sides both sides are controlled by the
same power that is always as you say
very important to remember
but the outcome
the synthesis
will be a death decree
against anyone that doesn't go along
with the system
right anyone
that contradicts the system
will have to go
and he
the second beast causes all
both small and great rich and poor free
and bond
to receive a mark in their right hand or
in their forehead so you either do what
you are told
and you do it
or you are ideologically convinced that
it is correct and you do it
but it is the mark of the first beast
and she has publicly claimed that the
mark of her ecclesiastical power is that
she
moved the solemnity of the sabbath from
the seventh day to the first day of the
week
that shows that she is above the bible
that her tradition is superior to that
of the bible it is an affront to the
authority of god it is a usurpation
of the authority of god
it actually
is exactly what satan wanted in heaven
yes he wanted to take over the authority
and he's using god's symbol of his
authority
where god specifically said remember
and then in order to implement it
they will make sure that you cannot by
yourself unless you go along with the
system and accept the mark of the beast
or the name of the beast now name always
stands for character
yes right yeah
so if you accept the name of the beast
that means that your mindset comes into
harmony with that of the beast you have
adopted its character whose character
are you supposed to adopt martin jesus
ah
so you're putting on a robe
that is not woven in a heavenly loom
so you're not covered by the
righteousness of christ you don't have
the righteousness of christ you have
another righteousness here which is
based on
works
almost sacramental works
keeping sunday
a command of the roman catholic church
that's a sacramental
issue then because it becomes a matter
of salvation you will be put to death if
you don't do it right
or the number of his name and his number
we know is 666
that's the number of rebellion against
god
so here is a prophecy martin that this
is going to happen on on earth and
because it's written there
no matter how much that sister tries to
retranslate it
this is what is going to happen
no matter what any theologian has to say
this is going to happen
all right so we will have to investigate
how this game is being played now as
we've said before
both sides of the fence
are being played by the same power
so whether we're looking looking at it
from the perspective of an east-west
conflict
whether we're looking at it from the
perspective of an ideological conflict
a liberal versus conservative conflict
or even a party alliance conflict
both sides are controlled by the same
power otherwise the egalian dialectic
won't work right exactly so
you cannot choose sides you cannot we've
said this all along the beginning you
can only watch it it's like sitting in a
real life theater situation
so at the moment we have wars and rumors
of wars
someone as we have said you can use any
of these dichotomies
to create the
dialectic right
so let's look at the war issue
can a war
influence public opinion one way or the
other oh definitely all right this
particular war that you have now
is it just a war regarding borders and
border encroachment or are there
ideological aspects associated with it
it's definitely got to do with
ideological aspects all right has russia
quite plainly and blatantly stated that
they do not want the liberal ideologies
of the west to spill over into their
region yes they've said that and also
putin has said
that
he haven't even said this is not a war
this is a
military exercise it's a military
exercise to set a matter straight yes
all right now there are various opinions
out there in the world
but certain opinions
appear to be suppressed
correct
well i've mentioned this quite a while
back
i used there used to be a few
channels on youtube that you could
watch that had some
russian news on it
you don't find any of that anymore all
right
so
if you want to make people inquisitive
one way to make them inquisitive is to
start censoring certain things
right
now if you take south africa for example
in the old days we had a sensor board
and the sensor board removed everything
that was even remotely
below the belt or
even ideologically
not
mainstream right
did it manage to suppress that or did it
actually make it more prominent the
opposite side it just
made it go underground and then very
prominent there and then when it
surfaced it became the norm right
so suppression has never really worked
no it works for a while but then you
have the opposite effect it may be also
part of the cia gillian dialectic plan
ah so
surely after 6 000 years
of experience
satan must know how the mindset works
right
so if you ban pornography does this does
it disappear no it thrives actually it
thrives right exactly
but you appear to be doing something
interesting right
so youtube removes more than 9 000
channels
relating to the ukraine war youtube has
taken down more than 70 000 videos
9 000 channels related to the war in
ukraine for violating content guidelines
including removal of videos that
referred to the invasion as a liberation
mission
now martin what makes youtube
so wise and who are the controllers of
youtube
that are so wise that they know what has
to be taken down and what has to remain
well they have to be part of those
making decisions okay and they're pretty
powerful organizational rights
so youtube's chief product officer neil
mohan said we have a major violent
events policy and that applies to things
like denial of major violent events
everything from the holocaust to sandy
hook and of course what's happening in
ukraine is a major violent event and so
we've used that policy to take
unprecedented action now who's the we
martin
we will never know
the first and probably most paramount
responsibility is making sure that
people who are looking for information
about this event
can get accurate high quality credible
information on youtube he said
so surely there must be an all-wise
individual or group of individuals that
know exactly what is accurate high
quality credible information
now what martin if the other side also
has
accurate high quality credible
information that may never be heard
would this make you inquisitive
definitely
would
especially when you want to hear both
sides
yes unless of course you're just one of
those people
that go with the flow and listen to the
first and
only
stream of information that comes towards
you
but be that as it may fear is a very
important factor in channeling the minds
of men
so let's have a look at some of the
developments in
russia and the
rest of the world
on the sidelines of the war in ukraine
another conflict is brewing between
moscow lithuania and the european union
last week lithuania decided to ban
transit of sanctioned goods to russia's
kaliningrad region to protest what
russia called provocative and openly
hostile measure according to the russian
foreign ministry the ban violates a 2002
russia eu agreement russia warned that
it would certainly respond to the
hostile actions a top ally of russian
president vladimir putin threatened
lithuania that moscow would respond in
such a way that the people of the baltic
state would feel the pain listenin
um
now following the threat warning from
russia the united states has thrown its
weight behind lithuania us state
department welcomed the economic
measures taken by lithuania against
russia over its invasion we have been
very clear
over the course of russia's war against
ukraine and in fact well before
russia began its unprovoked invasion of
ukraine
that our commitment to
nato and uh specifically our commitment
to nato's article five uh the premise
that an attack on one would constitute
an attack on all uh that commitment on
the part of the united states is
ironclad
so martin the russian spokesperson
said there would be serious consequences
and that there would be countermeasures
which would really hurt yeah
did he refer to misinformation from the
west
[Music]
so there are two sides to a story right
well not according to
youtube no and not according to
what the american representative said
now if you take russia
and the media for example
then russia isn't standing alone it is
associated with brics yeah
and bricks contains many countries
including southern africa south africa
and of course south american countries
and india and india and india is still
importing russian oil
so they're not all seeing it exactly as
youtube would want it right
so you've got a big portion if you
take it according to
population probably more than half of
the world's population yes on the other
side all right so is this a recipe for
hegelian dialectic
so
even if you leave the war out of it
which is fear there is an ideological
battle here right
okay now how far are these threatenings
going as an article from the independent
from the 23rd of june
2022 putin threatens to deploy satan 2
nuclear missile which can reach uk in 3
minutes by the end of the year
that would be by the end of 2022 right
it's interesting
that they are predicting a time
but it's always a little bit delayed
but it does create the possibility of
tension and fear
definitely
it says we will continue to develop and
strengthened our armed forces there's no
doubt
we will be even stronger he added
russia's defense committee deputy
chairman
alexey
zuravlioff
last month threatened to use its rs-28
sarmat hypersonic nuclear missile known
by
in the west as satan 2
to strike britain in just 200 seconds
the warning came after finland
indicated its intention to join nato if
finland wants to join this block then
our goal is absolutely legitimate
to question the existence of the state
if the united states threatens our state
it's good here is the some mutt for you
and there will be nuclear ashes from you
if you think that russia should not
exist
and finland says that it is one with the
usa
well get in line
so there are serious threats being
branded
and the world
might just be
in turmoil and fear
now fear is a is a great tool
to move minds
and
maybe people will think well why is
russia acting like this
do they have perhaps a legitimate reason
here and there
that's so important because once again
you can be
caught up on a side
you might just
listen to all this and he's conservative
and we've shown in the previous ones
the things that putin says
is more sometimes a little bit more
moral orientated
it's interesting that you have these
these moral tones coming from that side
and then you have the very liberal tones
coming from biden's side that's right
and a lot of laughing from
camilla harris's side
so yes we have definitely a clash here
and you can tend to then want to choose
a side yes even if it is
we're not choosing a side now let's make
that quite plain we're looking at the
hegelian dialectic
so modern if this is just a cold war
that is going to end up in a real war or
whether it is just ideological cyber
rattling
that the future will tell
we know what the ultimate outcome is
going to be
there will be an image to the beast
and that image of the beast will
implement ideologies
which are
part and parcel of the character of the
beast the roman catholic
system
that's what's going to happen
ask yourself the question
is rome associated and working
with both sides yes is that a fact that
in fact cannot be denied definitely not
is it only working with the political
parties or is it also working with the
media moguls
both
both even the corporations
everything
rome is at the hub so who's the puppet
master
the man in white
must be or the man in black or perhaps
yeah let's keep that one out because
we've got so many questions on that one
you've really put my your foot into that
one people want to know who is the grey
pope uh-huh
well you will have to didn't we talk
about him in the past no didn't we show
a picture of him in the past i think we
skipped him
the mancini's family real bloodline
and uh who that bloodline
or what that bloodline consists of and
who the kingpin is currently then you
have the white pope and you have the
black pope and together they're
recollective it's all it's all
it's very conspiratorial yeah is it like
the king of mana
yes something like that something like
that all right now
how how far is the cyber rattling going
it has to be
very convincing right
so let's have a look at another one and
see
what is happening
many had predicted the conflict in
ukraine will kick off another cold war
tonight we want to tell you it has
already begun
nato has put 300 000 troops on high
alert three lakh soldiers that should
tell you something what is a cold war
something that is not a typical military
war but involves proxy battles it
involves economic sanctions and often a
serious military buildup basically
everything other than what
fighting with weapons entails
troops will exercise together with home
defense forces
and they will become familiar with local
terrain facilities and our new
pre-position stocks
together this constitutes the biggest
overhaul of our collective defense
and deterrence
since the cold war
europe could become the next
battleground
it already is with ukraine but the war
in ukraine has proved to be a security
nightmare for the eu
it has no option but to prepare for a
wider conflict
america agrees with this assessment so
it will ramp up u.s forces in europe
the uk and germany say they will
contribute to the result is this a
massive build up on nato's eastern flank
we've reaffirmed that our article 5
commitment is sacred
and an attack on one as an attack on all
and we will defend every inch of nato
territory every inch of nato territory
together our allies we're going to make
up sure that nato is ready to meet
threats from all directions across every
domain land air and the sea
and the moment when putin has shattered
peace in europe
and attacked the very very tenets of
rule-based order the united states and
our allies were going to step up
we're stepping up we're proving that
nato is more needed now than it ever has
been and it's as important as ever has
been a total deployment of 5 000 troops
next is the united kingdom it will host
two squadrons of american f-35 fighters
the third location is spain two american
navy destroyers will be moved there
remember spain already has four american
destroyers so now it will have a total
of six
america is deploying air defense systems
too they will be sent to italy and
germany
but their biggest move will be in poland
here the us is planning a permanent
military headquarters the fifth army
corps of the u.s military will be
stationed in poland this is a combat
force
the focus here is on eight countries
estonia poland slovakia hungary latvia
lithuania romania and bulgaria
now nato has a strong presence across
this region
how many troops are we talking about at
least 324 000 soldiers 3 lakh 24 000
soldiers these are soldiers of the host
country and allied nations meaning these
are nato forces
plus the air defense equipment so nato
now has some serious fire power on its
eastern flank
it is a means to protect their own
interests that is with the hands of
ukrainians and the ukrainian people nato
members and leading nato countries
simply want to assert themselves further
assert their role in the world confirm
the leadership of their hegemony in the
trust sense of the word their imperial
ambitions
what would a russian mirror deployment
mean
more missiles more warships even nuclear
weapons russia may have made the nato
stronger but putin will not shy away
from sending a message
this conflict is only intensifying
martin in terms of
prophecy
is the tension and the hype increasing
in the world
it's getting to a boiling point
okay are there two sides oh yes
all right
now
can you clearly define them or are both
sides somehow represented everywhere
they represent it everywhere
the sides can be clearly identified with
direction
but not with ideology okay so we have to
move from this kind of conflict to the
ideological conflict as well because
basically it's going to boil down to
morality that's it
and moral laws
and those will be dictated by the first
beast whispered into the ear of the
second beast and implemented on her
behalf
by the second beast that's what prophecy
tells us what will happen
now i find it interesting that with this
escalation
doesn't it appear that we're reaching a
culmination point
yes it's actually
culminating towards a plan there must be
a plan behind it
satan is not out of control
he is a master strategist yes remember
he has a master general and he is
planning meticulously planning his
attack now who is attack who is his
attack directed towards well
god's people
and god yes he hates god
and he hates god's representatives on
earth those that keep the commandments
of god and hold to the testimony of
jesus they have to be eliminated
the rule of god has to go
if you this is a means to an end yes if
you put it like this um
although small
god's remnant
that is his ultimate goal because the
others are all collateral
yes and in any case wins that
if they don't choose to be part of
it doesn't matter what size they choose
they're choosing the wrong side right
so you have to be neutral in terms of
the worldly issues but you cannot be
neutral when it comes to the godly
issues or else you will be spewing out
of the mouth exactly so let's move from
the political
and the war
aspect to the ideological aspect roe
versus wade
every city every town
burned the precinct to the ground
so there were major upheavals after the
supreme court decision to overturn roe
versus wade
that sentence that you just read doesn't
it sound a lot like the french
revolution absolutely
and the french revolution
is the model
of what the world will be like
when the culmination point is reached
and we're there we can see it
so let's have a look at this little
construct that we've put together here
[Applause]
we're not scared of you
hey
[Applause]
because we're going to get a flood of
people i have declared this as our safe
harbor this is where we have the statue
of liberty welcoming people who are
oppressed women who cannot receive
fundamental right to control their body
or receive an abortion they are
oppressed they're welcome here in the
state of new york
until it takes its first breath
we have
so many problems with the supreme court
and the legitimacy this court has lost
legitimacy they have burned whatever
legitimacy they may still have had this
is a crisis of legitimacy and that
threatens the court's long-term
legitimacy the court is about to face
one of the largest threats to its
perceived legitimacy ever in its history
the supreme court has lost legitimacy
with the american people the crisis
of the very legitimacy of the united
states supreme court
fills me with sorrow
martin
this is the unbiased media
do they spread a buzzword around and
everybody repeats it
isn't that part of indoctrination
they should get biden to
use the word legitimacy and maybe
vice president harris could could have a
good laugh about it
[Laughter]
all right
jokes aside now
is this an emotional issue oh
it's a
you know they were so emotional on the
6th of january
i don't see anything
different
in this portion now actually martin
we're not allowed to say women anymore
it's now a birthing parent
and i don't know martin do you qualify
as a birthing parent unfortunately not
no all right
again jokes aside jokes aside
they serve a purpose joke sometimes
jokes aside it's a very serious issue
ideological issue
now
do people get angry
with regards to this issue yeah they
were at the senate almost breaking into
the senate okay
do we have a point of clash that could
become violent
in terms of the two sides i think we've
seen that already yes
all right so there is a definite
hegelian
dialectic going on here and again let's
ask the question
which organization worldwide
organization
has
consistently
been on the position that the supreme
court now actually verbalized
the roman catholic
it's a common factor right the majority
of the supreme court justices
are roman catholic as well okay now is
there therefore
an ideological
movement towards the sentiment of that
church
definitely
now the interesting thing is we're not
arguing the morality thereof because
they might actually be right in terms of
this point
could it be possible that if the
pendulum swings in their favor on this
moral issue
that the same pendulum could swing in
their favor with regards to other moral
issues which might not be biblical
definitely
like if i can ask it like this
nine of the ten commandments the
christians don't have any problem of
keeping
it's only one that they have a problem
with there's only one so they can have
all these
wonderful
rulings
but if there's one that's not in harmony
with the bible so they might get nine
very favorable rulings on their side
and then swallow a tenth one hook line
and cenco
but the other important financial
question is if the birthing parent is
able to travel and if they work for the
right company and are seeking an
abortion more individuals we're seeing
are going to need to rely on their
employer right for that financial
support to carry that out now for
example dick's sporting goods is now
telling us they're promising four
thousand dollars for any employee or
family member on their insurance plan to
access an abortion and there's a long
list of companies that are doing the
same thing you've got levi's and
starbucks yelp jpmorgan and many others
but the point here is katie is that
these benefits are provided because
these companies are willing to do it not
just because of their philosophy as a
corporation but because it makes
financial sense for them the real
challenge is going to be for the smaller
companies that can't afford to do this
and for the employees of those companies
that are unable to get access that way
and so there's going to be a tale of two
worlds if you work for a fortune 500
company in america today you very well
may get this type of health care uh as a
benefit smaller companies may not i
believe that eliminating the right of
women to make decisions
about when and whether to have children
would have very damaging effects
on the economy and would set women back
decades
well martin so the birthing parent no
matter who he is or she is can now have
all of these rights and you're getting
paid to have the abortion all right now
this this issue of birthing parent have
you ever had anything more ridiculous
than that
well it's no definition of a woman left
so that probably qualifies
all right so we're moving from the
sublime to the ridiculous
but there must be a point in it but i
also find it amazing
that the woman or the birthing parent
has the absolute right as to what
happens with the body except when it
comes to other issues where needles are
involved
then you have suddenly no rights how
does that work
once again you get to the youtube part
on who decides what's right and what's
good for you
so somebody decides now did you see all
those corporations
yeah the biggest all of those mega
corporations
are they somehow involved with the
vatican
we've shown that the fortune 500 uh
almost all of them
went to visit the pope okay so we have
the mega corporations
they're in on the game
we have the media they're in on the game
we have the religious world they're in
on the game
so there is a major hegelian dialectic
and the state is involved
and has the state the right
to
make demands or to implement legislation
that somehow impinges on morality yes
the
government does not have that anymore
but now the states do all right so now
are we moving towards an image of the
beast yes or no oh definitely yes okay
cbn news says
it justifies and excuses the intent to
kill a baby
california state assembly
passes amended infanticide bill
fight not over this comes from may 2022
where they had this bill now the
california state assembly on thursday
passed what pro-life advocates have
called the radical measure
that they've dubbed the infanticide bill
as cbn news reported
was opposed by pro-life groups who say
new language added to the proposed
legislation would shield a mother from
civil and criminal charges for any
actions or omissions related to her
pregnancy
including miscarriage stillbirth or
abortion or perinatal death
although definitions of perinatal death
vary all of them include the death of
newborn seven days or more after the
birth well modern then it's no longer
perinatal then it's postnatal
so
ab2223's amended language perinatal
death due to causes that occurred in
utero does nothing to change the bill's
protections for anyone who kills a baby
born alive during the first 28 days of
life the letter reads
martin
no wonder people get hot under the
collar because
this is infanticide as many will say
and yet the courts and the legislations
implies that you can have to actually
shift it so that it doesn't
become infanticide
now
this is a moral issue
and the moral issue again
sides with a position taken by the
vatican
so if we move from the abortion issue to
another issue
prayer public prayer
which of course was banned under the
the so-called constitution
and we look at that issue and another
court ruling
prayer ruling cnn's tuban threats
supreme court allowing more state
involvement with religion
cnn legal analyst jeffrey toobin argued
that the government was becoming more
involved with religion
after the supreme court decided that a
public school district didn't have the
right to stop a high school coach from
praying
alone after football games
so this man had been fired because he
was doing this at football games
and the court ruled in his favor
so reacting to the breaking news on
monday cnn's tuban blasted the decision
as the court
allowing more state involvement with
religion
all of that is part of a package and
that's what donald trump promised he
would deliver to supreme court and that
is precisely what he did delivered to
the supreme court tobin claimed
so is there a claim that church and
state is moving closer yes
and now there's some that are
glad for it yes and others that are
furious all right now what if you can
use these emotional issues and the roe
versus weight debacle and the violence
that comes out of it
to make people so disgusted with all of
this that the pendulum starts moving in
the direction
where prophecy says it's going to go yes
yes because prophecy
predicts that it will the pendulum will
actually end up
on the more conservative side which
church and state will be together
yes correct and society must be pushed
to the point where they accept this
ideologically
and the few that don't then
well they will have to receive the mark
in their hand
okay so actually it can be the other
side as well it can be either side but
you don't have to wait for a particular
party to win for this to be implemented
exactly because it qualifies that both
will be fulfilling the prophecy yes okay
now how high did the hype actually go
well
there were assassination attempts so
that says that it's pretty serious
and then there was tremendous criticism
of the government because they
apparently didn't do enough to protect
the judges
so the grand jury indicts man accused of
trying to assassinate brett kavanaugh
nicholas john ross 26 faces one count of
attempt
to murder an associate justice of the
supreme court
federal prosecutors said in a statement
so here is a story of a man who was
willing to go so far as to murder one of
the judges because of the decision that
was made
and then just to bring it back to the
political realm here is politico
and they say that trump actually said
god made the decision
overturning roe
interesting right remember he promised
that he'd do it yes
so here god made the decision former
president donald trump on friday
credited divine intervention for the
supreme court's decision overturning
decades of precedent protecting
americans rights to abortion access
god made the decision trump said in an
interview with fox news
this brings everything back to the
states where it has always belonged
trump also said this is following the
constitution
and giving rights back when they should
have been given long ago this decision
and others from the court that have been
hailed by conservatives
were only made possible because i
delivered everything as promised
including nominating and getting three
highly respected and strong
constitutionalists confirmed to the
united states supreme court
trump said in a statement issued friday
it was my great honor to do so he added
now it's interesting that he says they
are constitutionalists
whereas the others saying it's violating
the government they say the legitimacy
is gone all right so
actually what they're going to do
is to define
what is part of the constitution and
what lies outside of the constitution
and this is where sunday legislation
becomes very interesting
because if sunday legislation
comes under the mantle
of environment
and industry yes to give people rest
then it's not a religious issue no and
then it is constitutional yes and the
supreme court can vote that it is
constitutional
but will the churches be happy yes they
will be very happy they will be very
happy to violate the constitution
under
the mantle of environment and industry
all right
so martin
if it is also a religious issue and you
see that the violence is also directed
towards a particular church or
denomination
then it becomes even more interesting
right
so here's an article from june 28
2022 virginia catholic church targeted
with fire and graffiti after scotus
overturns roe
so do the people involved in this kind
of vandalism
know who's actually behind it
yes because they target the roman
catholic church all right
now for those that are against abortion
does this create a bond between roman
catholicism and them yes
is it clever
see how that gilean dialectic it works
perfectly that's how it works so police
in virginia have reportedly launched
arson investigation
after church was targeted with fire and
graffiti in the wake of the supreme
court's decision to overturn roe versus
wade
two of the messages read this won't stop
and
separation of church and state
now martin this is very interesting
because this is what we were speaking
about right in the beginning out of the
book of revelation
it's going to come about
this
image of the beast
does this kind of violence
again
create a bond of sympathy
with this ideology yes it does right
so the separation of church and state
eventually will be welcomed
by a large proportion of the society
everybody who is disgusted
with how far
the pendulum is swung to the liberal
side right
so on its website the saint john newman
catholic community church
has posted a link to a message from
bishop michael burbidge
of the catholic diocese of arlington
saying we thank god for this welcome
decision
of the supreme court overturning roe
versus wade this bond of sympathy
is incredibly important for the
fulfillment of prophecy that's it
because now you've had a catholic and
trump saying exactly the same all right
now is it only the bishop that was happy
no here's another article which says
that the vatican praises supreme court's
abortion decision says being pro-life
means supporting other issues as well
but they don't spell them out right
so is this a package yes the vatican has
praised the supreme court for standing
for life and reversing the country's
nearly 50 year old stance on abortion
pope francis previously compared the act
of abortion to hiring a hit hitman
but has steered the catholic church to
see pro-life as a larger issue than just
abortion
president joe biden a devout catholic
called friday
as the supreme court announced it was
overturning roe versus way a sad day for
america is this alien dialectic so the
president
of the image
is actually
against the image but for it as well
because he's part of it he's a catholic
now by his negative stance
is he giving the pendulum a push to the
right yes
he is right
martin this is very interesting
and
i believe this is
the end game no definitely
all of these issues
are a smoke screen
for
the
other issues
right
but the real aim is the other issue
now let's have a look what all of this
has done
to the image of the left
and how is the pendulum swinging if it
is swinging at all
well the new york post reported that cnn
ratings tank in first weeks under new
boss chris
licht
down go the ratings that's it now here's
a very
liberal
news media
and
it's tanking it's going down
so cable news giant cnn has seen its
viewership fall in recent weeks under
the helm of newly installed network
president chris licht according to the
latest nielsen ratings both msnbc and
cnn trail the ratings king of cable news
the fox news channel which is owned by
fox corporation now fox is more the
conservative side right
do we see a pendulum with pendulum
is swinging we don't have to read the
whole thing
but
the the picture is clear right
now normally it was
status quo
that the left pretty much stuck together
not only politically but also in the
ideology
but we see more and more
people that are supposedly left drifting
towards
the conservative side right
now here is a very
liberal man
jimmy dore
and he is making some noises that seem
to be indicating that he is fed up with
some of the very liberal ideologies and
ideas that are coming out of the lift
and he even stated some of these things
in an interview
that he had with tucker
so let's have a look at what he has to
say
so a lot of people got upset again uh i
got i went on tucker carlson what
yesterday
and
people don't like that i talked to his
audience so jimmy why do you go on
tucker carlson because they won't invite
me on cnn msnbc abc cbs mf what uh any
of the other ones
uh i will go to bring the message
uh
anywhere they will have me the binding
administration is blaming inflation
on putin
and so here we go
are you keeping a list of all the things
putin is doing
uh russia is very
powerful they control a lot of things uh
they overthrew our government they
committed a coup on america they control
the gas prices and the russia is
responsible for our inflation and let me
just tell you uh last time i checked
russia couldn't get their good vodka
into trader joe's so i don't think
they're really controlling everything
like they say they are okay uh so
the the democrats right now are in power
they have complete control of government
and like all politicians they don't want
to take the blame for anything they want
you to blame everybody and everything or
anybody and anything for the pain that
you're feeling right now except blame
them the people with the power right now
and so that's why everything comes back
to putin because putin is a pr proxy for
their trump hate right and you said
larry summers blamed january 6th on
inflation which is an old uh clinton
advisor so uh what what they don't want
us to realize is that we have the
unipolar government right so if you vote
for uh joe biden it it's you're voting
for goldman sachs if you mitch mcconnell
the same thing you're voting for our
oligarchy and they don't want you to
know that and as soon as people wake up
that we've been being screwed by the
same billionaires that control joe biden
that control the republican party that's
what scares them they don't want us to
they don't want me on your show talking
to your audience telling them that
people on the left we smell a rat and we
know that joe biden is completely
controlled by the oligarchy and the
corporations and right now the american
people are paying the price what are we
paying the price for not for putin's
inflation not for putin's gas hike this
is joe biden's invasion this is nato's
invasion this is joe biden's policies
these are joe biden's policies that are
wrecking the dollar that are propping up
the ruble to it's stronger than it's
ever been and they're blaming a foreign
country imagine if trump did that they'd
be making jokes about it every night on
the nightly news of course they're not
i'm not i mean the nightly talk shows
but of course they're not they're all
coddling you saw jimmy kimmel have to
coddle that old man the guy who probably
got stuck in a couch before he left that
place this is who's and you know joe
biden's not making the decisions we all
know that he's mentally impaired we all
know that kamala harris isn't making
those decisions because she also can't
speak in clear sentences so who is
really running the country well whoever
runs a democratic party which is a
handful of billionaires those are the
ones so if you're paying a higher price
they did a controlled demolition of our
economy with the coveted lockdowns and
nobody wants to take responsibility for
that coveted lockdowns which johns
hopkins university proved saved zero
lives they didn't make any impact on the
death rate whatsoever right so that they
don't want to take responsibility for
that they want you to blame your
neighbor they won't want you to be angry
at the oligarchs or fauci or big pharma
or the media that controls you that
makes you think that essential medicines
are poison they want you to blame your
neighbor if everybody is a trumper or
they're not it's you're with us or
against us and that is a that's the only
message they have left and then they
have censorship left because they have
failed tucker why do you think it is
that mitch mcconnell and chuck schumer
are the leaders in the house and nancy
in the senate and nancy is the leader in
the because they're not leaders those
people have negative charisma i wouldn't
ask chuck schumer directions to the
freeway why are they the leaders because
they're the ones who take the most money
from the billionaire class that actually
runs this country they take the money
from them and they disperse it to the
other members of congress so they vote
for them as leader not because they're
leaders but because they're the most
corrupt
he had quite a tirade
now i was i find it very interesting
martin
that he says that the politicians are
ruled by the oligarchs
and by the billionaires but i have
another question for him who rules them
it was going through my mind the whole
time we've shown over and over and we
can prove it still
they
go to one place they go to one place and
we'll talk about that in a moment
so
again let's go full circle
if you show part of a picture
then you don't see the whole picture and
you think this is reality this is the
world so people are talking about soros
or people are talking about bill gates
or people are talking about
musk or people are talking about whoever
swings the scepter none of them swing
the scepter there's someone else who
swings the scepter even we've had that
youtube one one twitter youtube all the
censoring where does it actually come
from didn't they all go to the vatican
definitely
all right let's have a look at elon musk
elon musk posted this on twitter right
martin is that what happened yeah he
asked this question after there was a
news article or a tweet
on cnn.com
about twitter that he's busy purchasing
and the question here is who funds these
organizations that want to control your
access to information let's investigate
and there you have twitter
now we know that elon musk was quite
liberal
and then recently he's made
very conservative noises
he's actually
publicly stated that he would change
party affiliation in the next election
so is there a trend
the swing and
now interesting
if you read the
last the the portion on why ask the
questions on
who's
these organizations and who's funding
them
so it says here brands should force
twitter to uphold content policies under
musk which brands
then he says some of the nation's
biggest brands including coca-cola
disney and craft are facing calls to
boycott twitter if the company's soon to
be obviously musk owner does not
uphold the policies all right now all of
these companies do they
form part of those companies that met
with the pope recently and came to a
particular agreement
at that particular institute right
definitely and after their meeting with
him
they were all of the sudden certain
policies
starting to be implemented okay so we're
still playing this game let's have a
little closer look here is a shirt or a
jacket that musk was wearing
at this
met gala function
and on the back of his jacket it says
novus ordo seclorum which means a new
world order
and
that's of course also part of the dollar
etc so
is he associated or
involved in this kind of thing yes
because some people might now say
this is actually an in-your-face
joke or
throwing it out there to show the the
new world order that he's not being
ruled by them but then some other things
that he do does
uh
might make you think twice about that
all right so
let's just take a step further
elon musk breaks twitter silence to post
photo of himself and four of his sons
with pope francis
so
the mega
billionaire has to
visit the pope and go silent during that
period
and there he presented himself now
martin why would it be essential that
these mega billionaires would have to
go and visit pope francis
to get instructions aha
so elon musk said he was honored to meet
pope francis as he shared a snap
featuring four of his sons after 10 days
of twitter
after last sharing a tweet on the social
media platform on june 21 the tesla ceo
51 returned to the site on friday
writing in a message feeling perhaps a
little bored
honored to meet at pontifex yesterday
musk wrote alongside the photograph
which saw each of the musk men standing
beside the pope in
suits
all black of course
most musk's most recent 10-day break
from twitter is the longest one he has
taken from the social media platform
since october
the wall street journal reported martin
why is it that every time
we discuss this issue
the vatican is involved
because the bible said it would be like
it
can't get around it cannot this is a
conspiracy or is it just a fact it's a
fact and there's a conspiracy going on
but it's a fact all right so
that man just said that the billionaires
control the presidents and the this and
that and the other
but we asked the question who controls
them does this give a little clue i hope
people can follow the clue
all right so having summed all of that
up
let's return to the bible
daniel 11 36 and the king
that's the king of the north
that's the papacy
shall do according to his will
and he shall exalt himself and magnify
himself above every god
that we find in the book of
thessalonians as well and he sits in the
temple of god showing that he is god
and he makes laws contrary to god's laws
and then he has some moral issues which
seem to be in harmony with god and he
presents himself as god taking the
authority of god
and getting the second beast to
implement it by joining church and state
as we have seen throughout this entire
presentation
and he shall speak marvelous things
against the god of gods
and shall prosper till the indignation
be accomplished
samatan is going to prosper the only one
who's prospering in all of this is the
paper senior
for that that is determined shall be
done no matter what some of our
theologians say
neither shall he regard the god of his
fathers nor the desire of women nor
regard any god for he shall magnify
himself above them all
he won't honor the god of his fathers
nor the desire of women women being
churches
he will not desire christ he has a
desire for the other one
but in his estate he shall
honor the god of forces
and a god whom his fathers knew not
shall he honor with gold and silver and
precious stones and pleasant things it's
the only religion that does that
the god of forces we had the whole
discussion of that on a previous one so
we won't go into that issue
verse 39
thus shall he do in the most strongholds
with a strange god he's not representing
god he's representing another deity the
dragon gave him his power and his seat
and great authority the one that wanted
to be god yes he's the god of forces
whom he shall acknowledge and increase
with glory and shall cause them to rule
over many and shall divide the land for
gain
he's playing games with countries
and at that time of the end shall the
king of the south push at him
that's an ideology that is contrary
supposedly to his
actually below the behind the scenes is
ying and yang sits at one table they sit
at one table
but for the sake of the the public
consumption
the king of the south shall push against
him in other words
the pope will say one thing
and biden will say the opposite
that's it did we see it yeah and you
even have it further
byron will say one thing and putin will
say another and they sit at
one table they sit at one table
and they belong to the little secret
societies
and the king of the north shall come
against him with the whirlwind he's
going to overcome that liberal ideology
are we seeing a pendulum swinging
with chariots is war involved
is he using war yes
with horsemen
is he moving his military around that's
it
and with many ships is he using the
economy
is twitter part of the economy or the
billionaires part of the economy economy
and he shall enter into the countries
plural
his ideology is going to go everywhere
and shall overflow and pass over martin
are we seeing a fulfillment of this
prophecy
definitely but
once again if you don't want to see it
like this this is conspiracy
but i believe it is biblical prophecy
and i believe
this is the end game
i believe with all of my heart
that we are in the culmination of
history
and may god give us spiritual eyesight
shall we pray
heavenly father
the table has been laid
the guests are
seated and the meal is about to begin
all the role players have been put in
place
the puppeteer is in total control
and
everything is working according to plan
and fortunately according to prophecy as
well
open the eyes of your people make us
aware of the times we are living in
unless it comes to us as an overwhelming
surprise
i pray in jesus name amen amen
[Music]
you